there's all kinds of criminals in this
world and they all have all kinds of
stories and your story is one
of I don't know if it came from
desperation versus a
love of this kind of
game right like it it wasn't part of it
an attraction to the the creative aspect
of this of breaking the rules when
nobody else can and you figure out a way
to do
it I think I think initially it was I
needed the money like that's the first
thing you know you you say oh okay well
I need and if you ask most guy oh well
man I need the money you need the money
but and then I I I definitely needed the
money but then you get $50,000 in your
bank and then you get A1 and then it's
200 and then it's half a million and
then it's a million and what the hell
are you still committing fraud for
you've got half a million or a million
dollars in the bank or worth of real
estate or you've you're making $5
$10,000 a month just in rental income
why are you still committing fraud so it
turn I think it morphs
into the creativity in part for me and
and two it was a chance for me to prove
to everybody how smart I was you know I
mean it was done out of desperation
initially and then it just turned into
pure narcissistic arrogance look at me
look at how I can do things that nobody
else can do look how smart I am I just
walked in the Bank of America handed
them seven documents that were all
fraudulent and they cut me a check for
$250,000 like wow I'm amazing you know
and guess what they're never going to
get their check and they they won't know
even know where to start to try and find
the person because they're looking for a
phantom so you know and you feel great I
felt great I used to I I I felt like I
felt like James Bond I felt like7 it was
amazing and you know and it did it it
feeded my need to feel important you
know even if it it it was it was even if
that was a lie cuz all that success was
just a
lie well no you were good at it it was
good at it but it was it's not it was
illegal it's not like I'm Elon Musk you
know what I'm saying like there's it's
not like you're an ex I'm an exceptional
human I'm an exceptional human being at
a horrific thing at at committing fraud
well the question is how many people are
getting hurt because uh initially the
thing is initially nobody got hurt
that's the thing nobody ever lost any
money directly like I didn't go and say
give me $50,000 and I ran off with your
money like I wasn't doing that and that
was a great
justification but at some point and
we'll get into that you know I take off
on the run and people do lose money I I
didn't take that money directly and for
some reason in
my you
know sick mind or whatever the case may
be that seems like a distinction to me
that makes me feel okay is it I never
said give me 300 give me $110,000 and I
ran off with it but I put in a position
where
I damaged the credit or damaged the the
title to their
house and they had to go get a lawyer to
fix that you know and and so that they
had to go pay a lawyer $110,000 so I
absolutely caused that person did I said
to me to you're a victim and I owe you
that money and it was a shitty thing to
do because even at the time I was like
oh they'll make a couple phone calls
it'll be fine it wasn't fine and if I
had really put any thought into it at
all I would have known it it's going to
it's going to really affect these people
and those people had done nothing
wrong with the exception
of trusting me they rented me their
house or they owner finance their house
they made the mistake of bumping into me
and now they owe $10,000
$20,000 you know and and I'm sure a ton
of
anguish